so you thought this was a dead meal
did you know meme is dead until I say so
my name is PewDiePie I'm level 5 man
like you don't believe me I'm so mad I
drink monster
from like the last
[Music]
through my glass
let's review some other man lands to
bring back life into mad lights please
if anyone ever refers to any of my work
as a man they they will be immediately
blocked this is not a joke look at Brian
here with a saw you should look in face
don't do it Brian that's too crazy don't
challenge how him whatever hope this
turns into a me you know what this toast
goes out to you Brian
namaste that's some fine monster energy
drink y'all ever just say hi and eat it
with the shell okay
you can't eat it with the shell you
could die that's dangerous you can't
digest paper like food everyone knows
that it's he okay is he okay please we
need to report this to make sure that
other kids don't see this and do the
same thing this is not a joke just
kidding I actually don't care
Madeline I saw a post on here about a
guy who had irrational hate for odd
numbers so he opted modes supposed to
make them even so now I offered even
post in order to make them odd and spite
him mad that's crazy he's gonna get
super angry
I saw a Babu in real life ask me
anything
your mom doesn't count yes but your days
if this post no no no no no no no if
this post gets 30,000 likes I will drink
this glass of water don't do it
hey guys guess what I have a girlfriend
now
damn and I kiss and love her ha ha
april fools you idiots I still very much
alone
you dumb ex mall watching an anti weed
documentary while stoned hold the camera
you can't do that
you can't just watch an anti weed
documentary while stone
do you understand that's so
irresponsible mad lad some people are
just crazy out there what are they gonna
do next
permabanning anyone who calls me
PewDiePie that's right that's right
mother
that's right looking sharp there pute my
luck also note how I didn't say
PewDiePie I said pues I'm two steps
ahead of anyone that's a even thinking
that they're a man land the graffiti in
my hometown is getting out of control
swear words I like this guy I like this
guy he's like this will probably make it
to the mad red man ledge subreddit and
PT pi will review it and he can't review
memes with swear words in it or else his
video will get to monetize so I'm gonna
be responsible here thank you
appreciate you all right what do we have
here a youtube link scribbled into stone
it leads to Rick Ashley's never gonna
give you up how can you be so crazy how
do you even think of this stuff you
gotta be completely cuckoo out of buku
ad go ahead skip this ad me okay all
right this is just too far this is too I
have to be responsible here because if
you hit skip and then that means I don't
get as much revenue unless you watch it
thirty Seconds through okay so please be
responsible here don't take this too far
okay my little brother added Mia Kelly a
into who is that into his bald photos
and both my parents have come commented
on how nice the photo is oh what's a
great picture you have here you finally
made a girlfriend guy lives next to
airport painted this on roofs to confuse
passengers as they fly overhead
he lives in Milwaukee that's it that's
his Cleveland my god this man needs to
be arrested and sending to Matt Ladd
party town cuz that's where epic people
go like this man friend requests I have
been idling in his inbox for like six
years but at last I am finally able to
conduct the sickest bird in American
history his name is Brian best Brian
worse accepted your friend request
Brian best - Brian worst circuit this is
the power of man lands this is the
strength that it contains are you able
to handle it I don't think so
hahaha just prank my flatmate by opening
up his pack of eggs and rearranging them
so he won't know which eggs are which oh
my god like oh no no sorry but now I
have to pick the pause button guys don't
do this think about the person that you
are dealing with sometimes pranks can be
funny because both parties are laughing
afterwards
that doesn't happen it's not a prank
it's worse is bullying you know you know
it's worse is mean no it's words it's
really bad it's there if there was a
worldwide game of hide-and-seek where
would you hide not telling you
whoa whoa whoa okay
please hit the pause button right now
don't actually do it that would be crazy
you hit the pause button in you
hi I knew you were a man lad I knew you
were my again men gets two years in
prison for claiming he created Kung Fu
Panda can we get an F in the chat guys
this is people that push the limit oh
man lad to see where he can take them
and society wants to shut us down but
two years in prison that'll mean nothing
because people will know that I'm the
one that created Kung Fu Panda 2 when
you eat cereal
do you use milk in it I use water damn
damn damn
damn Madeline hmm
damn damn some people are just hard some
people are just hard they've been
through things they've seen things it
changes things things have changed for
people people are hard so am I just
kidding this whole ligament trend is so
stupid
true only so good these people find it
funny oh it's coming
guys hit pots right now what's sue
Gandhi's so Gandhi's nuts
ah if if only that would happen if that
was me I would just quit YouTube because
I'm officially peach hey guys do me a
favor
what is this Pokemon called right on my
ass bill what are you gonna what are you
gonna do smash like on this video but
you don't have the bows you don't have
the boss whatever what it takes I think
that's enough man line for one day thank
you guys for smashing like on this video
[Music]
remember we added the merch for four or
more days in case you missed it in case
you're an absolute man land and buys one
of each item that would be crazy don't
do that that would support the channel
and give me more revenue that would be
crazy
that would be insane you can't just do
that now
[Music]
alright goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]